how I talking about some applications of
this CH SH group or digiti serum in
terms of how we can use it to control
untrusted quantum systems this is yes
this is joint work with bottom of the
mesh so
basically we showed before that if when
you play lots of co tested games and
sequences for and the devices win enough
of them in this forces the only way this
is possible is if they share quite a lot
of entanglement and if they measure this
is king about in a very nice way but
that's not so interesting and in
particular you know when you when you're
done playing the games they've used up
all the entanglement that you showed
they had session the games destroy the
entanglement just as much as age sure
that you have it so today I just want to
show you how how this kind of theorem is
actually still useful even though it
seems like it's just foregoing the
entanglement and how we can use this
kind of theorem to force these quantum
devices to actually do whatever we want
to prepare arbitrary quantum states as
long as so you can efficiently prepare
them or full quantum computation so the
model it I want to talk about is
delegated computation which we heard
about yesterday it's the idea this
cryptographic idea that you have some
weak device like a cell phone or some
computationally week device there's some
powerful server and the cell phone wants
to outsource some computation to the
server a known computation to this
server so it's not like homomorphic
encryption and you want to guarantee
primarily that the server's output is
correct even though you don't trust it
to do something so you want you need to
come out building traps or checks or
some way of making sure that it's doing
the computation you ask it to and second
the nice property is that the
computation is secret this is actually
quite easy to achieve for for us at
least so the server doesn't actually
know what you're doing what what he's
doing to this data except the most basic
properties like the size of the circuit
requirement
is it a requirement no because otherwise
you won't be able to which property is
the no I mean actually and maybe the
circuit itself is secret not just the
data the secret so you could have a
scheme where you tell the prover what
the circuit is and the data is somehow
encrypted so he doesn't want he doesn't
learn the data you but you force him to
apply the circuit but yes something like
this so classically you know it's been
studied for a long time and the fair
favorite is known here here's here's
some brief results but I also skip over
that I'll just mention instead what we
heard from Monday about sort of semi
quantum delegation so I forget exactly
what Joe called it so the idea there was
that you start with some quantum circuit
that you're interested in and you
compile it into this into this protocol
where we have one device that is able to
create quantum state simple quantum
states like one qubit quantum states
just like cat theta where that's cosine
theta cosine theta and its senses
quantum states over simple quantum
states over to a fully quantum server
and there's traps and brickwork States
and whatever in order to make sure that
the quant improver applies some
interesting quantum circuit
uh but but this is not fully delegated
quantum computation because we still
need the ability to prepare these
quantum states and that's quite helpful
in the analyses so today I really want
to talk about fully delegate fully
delegated quantum computation and
unfortunately I don't know how to do it
just nobody know decide to do it with
just one classical verified one quantum
server but so what we'll do is we'll
have to quantum servers Alice and Bob
who are untrusted their entangled with
each other potentially know they'll have
to be entangled if they want to win but
then everything else is fully classical
so the very very far is fully classical
all the messages to and from the
approvers are fully classical well then
the idea is that again it said you're
going to run this big protocol so the
verifier is going to ask for all these
tests it to be played and provided that
these tests provided that there's a good
probability of passing all these tests
the conclusion of the theorem is going
to be that they they had they applied
the circuit you ask them to and the
result is correct yeah so maybe maybe
before I try to explain how this works
only try to ask why it's why is even a
problem so there's there's sort of an
obvious approach here and that may mayor
my network so so the obvious approach is
just to take what we already know so
take this protocol that take this semi
quantum or semi classical delegated
computation protocol and then sort of
split off half of it so so we need to
verify to prepare these one qubit
quantum states so let's let's just give
that to Alice and let Bob be to play the
role of the quantum server in getting
this in this original protocol and then
so we asked Alice now to prepare these
one cubit stays now we can they share
entails so we can teleport them over to
Bob and then run the original protocol
right so so uh so what's wrong with that
I mean um well one simple thing is to
make sure that alice is sort of honest
like she's really teleporting over she's
really creating and teleporting over to
Bob the
the right one keep it states the one
that the ones that you asked her to
prepare that doesn't seem like it's a
serious problem I mean you just you know
in some random subset of the positions
you'll ask Bob to measure in the basis
data J theta J plus PI over 2 and you
make sure that he returns the right
angle right and that that provides a
check on Alice so if she's preparing
some state that's far away from cat
theta from cat theta J when you ask her
to prepare it then this measurement will
catch it should catch it and you know
that should work because actually all
these angles are uniformly distributed I
think they're like uniformly random
multiples of pi over eight in this ski
we saw my do so so so really Bob should
have no idea what what angles are coming
in so if you asked him to measure in
this basis he's no idea what would basis
what would answer to give and so he kind
of has nothing better to do than he
better be measuring and in returning the
answer that should catch I should catch
Alice I just understanding do you assume
that Ellis picks her own theta or that
the classic of Arafat has added le
switch theta 2 to the bottom I don't do
everyone probably hello every because
it's our home second the songs country
to me that you are so i should say this
is an obvious protocol this is the wrong
protocol I mean I'm not gonna try to
analyze this protocol so I don't know
exactly how you can figure out the
details to make something just confused
because it was once a different version
5 l can understand it was in structures
there snakes if Alex chose them herself
then she could just
okay Chris I'm only want you presume
about the verifier to give the round of
Miss Dallas like just sends like a
random number for 128 and that tells
Alice which is the eighth day today
states to prepare because I but
otherwise yeah she was prepared some
sort of it wouldn't really be a random
string and she could coordinate that
with Bob um so that's sort of the idea
this kind of scheming or you could do it
with any any sort of semi quantum scheme
and you could try to break it up in this
way and have Alice do the do the stay
preparation part of that Bob is a
computation party it seems reasonable
and maybe you need a few more tests than
this it seems reasonable you can make
something like this work maybe the
problem is it's it's really hard to
analyze this kind of scheme I mean so
the first problem is maybe not so
complicated i don't know like it could
be that Alice sends some other states
I'm saij into theta J and Bob doesn't
exactly measure in the theta J theta J
plus PI over 2 basis but he does
something slightly different and somehow
they conspire so that their answers
always seem like they always give the
right answer even though but not quite
doing the right computation I don't know
but maybe you could analyze this and
ensure that that can't happen but I
think maybe a more interesting problem
with the kind of argument is is that the
cheating strategies could be much much
more sophisticated than just sending the
wrong quantum state I mean it could be
that Alice doesn't even send qubits to
bog it could be that they don't even
share entangled key bits maybe they
share some other kind of entangling and
I mean maybe maybe the Alice isn't
sending information and tensor product
she's just sending some large state
maybe Bob's measurements aren't in
tensor product what he measures in the
first on the first suppose that cupid
the second supposed two qubit they
overlap in some complicated way it's
very hard to try to analyze this kind of
scheme when you have no control over
exactly what they're doing there's
there's no idea there's no notion of
even of locality or anything
have found on the classical information
that is transferred because it has to go
to the third level so if yes well verify
will know that they are the most n to n
bits transfer for this tool for this n
qubits that should be teleported and
then if the verifier checks a subset
like ask the the second prove are two
open a subset of the bits back then it
might be that you could use the amount
of information that has to be
transferred and see that there can't be
any extra information transfer because
it just doesn't fit
you're going to you're trying to
understand the quantum state not the
classical inclination that eventually
you're interested in a quantum
computation exactly the verifier wants
to make sure that the that a did not
send anything except the quantum states
to be so not the classical description
that's what you want to ensure what
you're saying is just binding the
decidedly state with the amount of
information with you actually want to
know what it is tension borrow 50 2 j's
I don't want to know that at the things
I all I want to know is ready soon all I
want to know is that the blue circle
down there that he only gets these
quantum states and possibly possibly
different encoding whatever but you
should from the information that edited
at the verifier sense you should not
would not get anything more about the
encoding about the angles then the
encoded quantum state and if additional
information center could be seen there
may be other proven anywhere on them and
so again let me say just one thing huh I
don't know how to prove that this image
does not work yeah but because from the
teleportation you always get random bits
which I was asked to tell verifier you
verify anything to get the patient
rivers any protocol that I know enabled
Alison Bob to decide on the shared
random string full the verifier to it
it's not I'm not smart enough to look
all that would bypass no no I share i
use normal to the protection protocol
yeah and the classical bits need to go
to edit so they're so let me write them
so this is a dog can pre arranged and
say whatever they move it will satisfy
the very fact he needs to accept no well
anyway anyway I'll see what this kind of
scheme is secure
for sure we don't have any
counter-examples kind of samples would
be like a cheating strategy that works
will be very interesting or also of
course a different analysis but i guess
i just want to point out that without
any understanding of what the hilbert
spaces of alice and bob are or what the
quantum state that they have is it's
very it's really hard to try to push
through some kind of analysis and so
this is really sort of immoral and is
that this theorem that we showed before
that when you play lots of CH SH games
the only way of doing it and
successfully is to have a tensor product
structure that really allows us to to
limit out the ways that Alice involved
can cheat in this kind of protocol and
then you can suddenly start to construct
this into quite simply into into
theorems like delegated quantum
computation so so we are able to show
this kind of this kind of result but in
a different approach not not via these
semi classical semi quantum protocols so
okay so so seems you have to modify the
protocol and it's possible that there
could be a rigidity theorem for the
original protocol also yeah it's
possible to use you use the rigidity
theorem for CH sh then that gives you
the tensor product Crocker with you then
apply to them exactly yeah and let me
also say that this kind of in a sense it
has is his problem that motivated a lot
of this work which was how do you
characterize you need to block box
devices you don't know anything about
what's going on inside them they could
even be adversarial and you want to
characterize and understand what their
quantum state is and it's this kind of
result lets us do that actually it's
more than just elated quantum
computation so it in delegated
computation it just says I know I know
that the mathematical result of the
circuits that I asked I know the result
of the circuit that I got is is the same
as what it should have been
mathematically but actually this Arthur
theme I'm saying something stronger it's
actually allowing us to characterize the
internal quantum states of these of
these quantum devices at every step of
the protocol and so it's really a
physical statement not just a
mathematical statement
I guess so sort of a classical delegated
computations either be no hope I'll both
ago of characterizing what's going on
inside the server it's just doing the
computation in some way somehow you get
the right answer but here we really are
characterizing what's going on inside
the quantum server and we can ask it not
just to do a computation we got asked
you to prepare some interesting quantum
state and it would do so I mean what you
do with it but it would have this
quantum state in its memory up to a
change of basis so there'd be some some
interaction or something in which you
can see that what you're saying is they
attack yeah and so that's why I say
that's why I say it's not clear how
interesting it is to know that he is a
quantum state because it's up to a
change faces right but it's still
somehow different rooms from the
classical picture I think all right so a
second theorem that comes out of this is
is that cute mathematically q my p
eagles and IP start so let me just say
what this means it means that if you
started a quantum multi cooper
interactive proofs so you see the
quantum of a sentence set of quantum
improvers who are entangled in the bad
guys i Nev this quantum verifier in
quantum messages and the exchange
messages to decide some language so
that's Q my P MIP star is the same it's
again you have quantum provers but the
verifier is fully classical which means
that the messages are also classical and
then they're entangled so so clearly
sort of any protocol of this form is
also of that form I mean the classical
verifier is a special case of a quantum
verifier and so mathematically that
means MIP star is contained in q IP so
the same and that we show is actually
the other direction q IP is contained an
MIP star in other words we show that
starting with a protocol like this you
can simulate it with the protocol like
this on the right so starting with the
quantum verifier you can simulate it
with a classical verifier the way our
proof works actually as we add to prove
errs Alice and Bob and Alice and Bob and
the verifier together essentially run
the delegated quantum computation
protocol
so so these two together are I guess the
verifier delegates this quantum circuit
to Alice and Bob in order to run this
protocol if that's the idea and I don't
know it might it might or might let me
be necessary to add to prove errs maybe
you can do it by reusing like r 1 and r
2 y's are p1 and p2 but we don't know
for sure so this is this I'm a
mathematically these are just classical
languages decidable by a protocol like
this the statement is always like it's
just standard completeness salute
sweetness yeah exactly yeah ok explain
what's the difficulty in using the r1
and r2 to also simulate the first time
um I don't know that there is a
particular difficulty a lot of the
problems that we face is writing a
theorems so maybe if you write down the
theorem carefully then you probably be
able to probably be able to prove it
like there's no conceptual difficulty I
don't think it's mostly mmm you just
have to be careful that all the all the
quantum information is in the right spot
at the right time and doing it like this
sort of allows you to isolate isolate it
more easily yeah
yeah so in the second place you've got
classical messages to the bread is but
is there some sort of teleportation
where they that simulates the quantum
messages on the left side yeah actually
so can I say something here so I
actually the quantum messages can all be
passed by it by classical teleportation
so you don't need I mean I mean all
these quantum messages are passed by
classical teleportation to Alice and Bob
we're really compute on them but you
just mean teleportation miss classical
sorry palpitation right maybe another
point as well is is that the round
complexity is not very good either so
there's this point of adding Coover's
which probably we can fix I don't know
there's another problem which is around
complexity very bad which I definitely
do not know how to fix so it's known
that qi p can be paralyzed down to just
three rounds of communication so this
way this way this way sorry or the other
way whatever um but but that's not known
for MIP star and the way are the way our
proof works and certainly it blows up
there on complexity quite a lot because
you need you need some rounds of
communication to simulate every single
gate of this quantum circuit over here
and so the round complexity is going to
be like the size of the quantum the
quantum verifier circuit something like
that polynomial in there anyway um
that's the best we know
the protocol that you impose the
rigidity the complexity sorry hear ya on
the right um no I'll show in a second
you'll see um in two sectors okay so let
me say something about how I Holly prove
this your first ingredient is this
theorem from before about understanding
a sequential CH sh again so here we have
these two provers Allison Bob we send
the we send these random bits we get
back response ism and they should
satisfy some simple predicates and
here's the optimal strategy when you
play multiple games so if you feed
Allison input one she should have pipe
okay so they should share an epr pair
for every game first of all and secondly
if you pee Dallas and if it once you
should apply pie break here to measure
in the sea basis and return the result
if you feed her a zero you should
measure she should apply it she should
measure in the X basis rotated by
poverty and Bob what he does is on input
one he measures and X basis on if it's
here images from the sea basses this is
the optimal strategy and it wins every
game with probably about cosine squared
pie 48 which is about eighty-five
percent and so we've mentioned last time
you is that if you start with an
arbitrary strategy for playing n times n
of these games sequentially and if
there's a high probability that they win
the optimal fraction of these games then
if you stop them at the beginning of a
random block of little n games the state
of the quantum system at that point is
going to be any PR Paris and the
strategy for the next two little end
games is going to be exactly the
strategy in this picture approximately
especially in this picture um and of
course when they play that they destroy
the entanglement but okay
so that's that's the first ingredient
which which gives us structure and this
is really the most important of course
and in creating the proof let me point
out something that English also
mentioned on Monday which is the CPR
pairs is really nice it has this
property that if you measured in any
basis like like the theta theta plus PI
over 2 basis if Alice measures is in
that basis it collapses Bob decides for
the same state that's two more generally
as well if you take any PR pairs and you
measure in any orthonormal basis like
psy X whatever result Alice gets bob has
the same state up to complex conjugation
so it's a collapsing one half collapses
the others have to the same thing here's
the proof I'll skip it um the second
ingredient is computation by
teleportation so if you haven't seen
this before well here it is this is
actually it's the same as a standard
teleportation circuit except I put a
hammer art here so standard
teleportation would take an input and
you get out the output here with some
poly correction or heat here with some
poly correction which you can fix but
since I put a hammer here it sort of
feeds in so the side comes in you gets I
hear you get h side here so you
teleported into a hat like gate for free
and it means that instead instead of
applying how to read gates to your data
you just prepare these resource states
and then teleport into these resource
states and then the computation happens
in the cocking the politician so so well
here's here's another example so i
prepared a 40-bit resource state with
two epr pairs and a scene out between
them I i apply these dell measurements
which is just my shorthand for this
little circuit here um applied Bell
measurements in both of the data cubits
and what comes out is to see not applied
to the data Cupid's that's teleporting
to it see not getting if you do it with
whatever you want no a lot of a lot of
different things so so here's another
example a more complicated example and
I've sort of compiled into all the gates
of this circuit I've compile it into
resource days like this had emerged
becomes a bell pair with that have
martyr the second half c naught is that
that for qubit resource
and there's a bunch of Bell measurements
that probability into each step of the
circuit so the way we're going to use
this is we're going to all these e PR
pairs women we're going to split half
half is going to be on by Alice half is
going to be on by Bob all the veil
measurements we're going to say Alice
does it Belle measurements and weight
actually that's wrong sorry sorry it
start over what we're going to do is
we're going to ask Bob to prepare these
states fully on his side these resource
states we're gonna ask alice to apply
the belt measurements fully on her side
and then the wires between them were
going to do by another round of
teleportation along those shared epr
states so so the picture is this now
this picture here implements the same
circuit by teleportation computational
application so it's the same CH SH it
looks like alright so they share these
epr pairs so here we have kept 0 comes
in because Bob is measuring the first
keep it in the Z basis that collapses
Alice's first qubit to get 0 then it she
does a bell basis measurement which
moves it over to this to this give it
here on Bob side he teleports into a hat
Marty gate so to keep it moves around
out here and so on you need to sort of
trace the data through the circuit and
see that implementing this same picture
here it just sort of wraps between back
and forth between Alice and Bob so the
point here is that Alice has a bunch of
resource states for the different gates
but she doesn't know what order they are
applied in
for blindness yeah that belly don't
never seen arcade since I macadam
arcades good lawd knows what order
they're in but he doesn't know what gave
his way that you know well you want in
the gate to engage three but doesn't
know which is gave one who's a good to
really you can think of it as yeah so so
so so Bob owns these resource or Bob's
the guy who's tasked with creating these
blue these blue blocks resources aids
and and so and so when Bob and actually
when Bob creates this resource date
because of this property of collapsing
appear pairs in Los it'll actually be
created on analysis side so Bob will
make a measurement on his side Mike
he'll make this two qubit measurement
and that'll collapse the corresponding
cubits analysis side into the into the
correct resource state so when Bob's
done if he's honest he knows that Alice
has all these resource states and then
these these belper measurements they
sort of wire them up in the right way so
the data goes into the right quantum
state out of the quantum state into and
out and actually the reason the round
complexity is high is because this has
to be done adaptively because ur its
universal circuit he exactly not in this
picture but yeah other questions
okay and finally the third ingredient is
set sort of like what we're trying to
get to we're trying to get to this
protocol where they do this computation
by teleportation but they could do
whatever they want so we have to force
them to do that let me do that is by
certifying that they would be asked so
for example on how do we know that Alice
applies build measurements when he asked
her to yeah well so what we're going to
do is we're going to sort of play half
CH SH games so we're going to keep on
asking Bob to play CH SH teams so he's
none the wiser he still has to keep on
measuring the X and Z basis depending on
what we ask him to but will tell Alice
on the corresponding qubits to do this
bill measurement and she could do
whatever she wanted um but the point is
actually that if by chance we asked
Alice tumut at Bob to measure X tensor X
or Z tensor Z so we know we're asking
random XZ z x XX there's easy but if
it's one of these two possibilities the
bell states are eigenstates of of those
two poly operators and so his the parody
of his measurement results should tell
us exactly should be the agree with
Alice's measurement result here that's
the idea and then that should force us
that should force Alice to actually
apply a bell measuring because if she
does something else it won't create the
right stabilizer state and city will
catch here this sounds exactly like the
kinds of tricks I mentioned at the
beginning that don't necessarily work
and but now it does this kind of
strategy you can analyze and it does
work because we know that there's a nice
tensor product structure so you can
justify sort of standard tomography
kinds of arguments
and really so this is how it's gonna
work we mix these half CH SH games with
the full CH SH games in random position
and in in a random position we ask a
listed to a bell measurement between two
random pairs to two random cubits and
she has no idea our bob has no idea and
so he'll he'll catch her if she tries to
cheat because he still thinks each of
the teams that's really good to mix the
games in with everything else and this
is similarly on the other side so if we
what if we want Bob to prepare a certain
resource state by applying this
measurement circuit which will collapse
Alice's keep it to the research state we
just have Alice keep on playing the CH
SH games without telling her that Bob's
stopped and and now you just verify that
the statistics of Alice's measurement
outcomes agrees with the tomographic
statistics that you would expect from
from making these kinds of measurements
of this particular quadruped state so
here's sort of the picture that we do
know how to hi well this is sort of
again it's an intuitive picture so here
in red this is the computation by
teleportation part of the circuit where
Bob is being asked to prepare these
resource states hopefully is alice's at
being asked to prepare these to apply
these bill measurements hopefully she is
between random pairs of qubits and then
but we we also need checks on Bob so
that's this sort of golden color so
alice is applying half CHS atms and
babas doing this we've checks on Alice
the screen stuff and then we have these
cases where they're both applying CH SH
and this is not a scale I mean most a
tiny fraction is circuited is a comp
tation the new more checks and then
you've many more CH SH games than even
that of course you need to randomly
permute things so that they don't know
what's going on they don't know which
which ones are CH SH games and which
ones are tomographic Jackson which ones
are computational
pation um something totally I think this
is this could possibly work but again
actually but I don't know how to analyze
this this picture unfortunately but what
we can is a following picture so it's
more instead of mixing things up with
each other which hopefully works we just
mix the protocols fully side by side so
it's probably 143 plet play CH sh games
about one-fourth we do Alice Jack's ball
with power lines of course we do
volunteer class promote one fourth week
we do full computation and so really
what that means is that if you look at
this theorem the theorem said that if we
play this many see Jessica CHS a chance
and we stopped before a random block
then the that next block is being played
honestly and so when I say mix between
these protocols what it what I mean is
in the second protocol you play many CH
SH games and then before random block
you stop and you start playing this
vertical because in that random block
you know that alice is still playing CHS
atms even if Bob's being asked to do
something different now sorry can I just
clarify that so you're gonna play a
bunch of blocks that are always CH SH
games yeah and then for a few selected
blocks you're going to randomly just one
block just wanted to stop in one block
and I'm going to do all this stuff or
I'm gonna do one of these three things
ok and I don't mix anything out so I I
only choose one of these three things
and stop ok so you only get the answer
with probably 14 52 Cisco yeah can you
show us the view
so so so much I would we improve it here
by replacing an approximately one with
approximately into some power so I
entered into some constant into some
minors so we were the difficulty oh no I
don't think there'd be a difficulty I
think I'll be fine because you just make
an argument that you just repeat it
about a bunch of times and classically
say that if let's say let's say it's one
half not not into the wind so it ever so
say we try to make this one half you
just repeat the protocol a million times
and say that so there's a probably one
half of caffeine move them all and
probably passing them all is probably
passing the first block times of
probably passing the second block
condition on the first block times are
probably passing the third block
condition on the first two and so
overall the product of these is at least
one half that means most of them have to
be at least 1 minus epsilon so then
there you go so you can amplify it like
that yeah so therefore you could
increase the inferior means come on your
phone by saying that summers the posse
chance non-negotiable is 1 over a verse
point on there
yeah I think just like sort of classless
assists statistics arguments like this
yeah um ok so I think I'm out of time
and there's a lot of other things here
hey maybe let me just finish and if
there are other questions maybe you can
just ask me other questions because this
is there's a lot of more technical stuff
but I think I've given you the big
picture of how how you can it's really
this idea that you stop them at the
beginning or end a block that's really
how you how you get the tensor product
structure which makes it all work small
a comment you can derive the brick wall
construction that your show using
teleportation if I get yeah I mean
cluster state's interpretation is the
same that's right yeah so I yeah I think
this is just one way you can lick a very
tidy proof I mean there's a lot of
similarities yeah but I mean I mean
there's a really sort of fundamentally
CH sh games if you don't know how to
make some in a nice way because our
virginity theorems not strong enough to
allow them to allow us to mix them in so
I mean I believe it i mean we don't know
how to analyze this picture here
I I only know how to analyze the case
when either you place HSE games or you
do computation or you do tomography and
put maybe you can prove some Dunham and
if you have more sort of diverse zoo
rigid games to tap into where you know
the rigidity would say well here you're
doing an X and you see you're doing also
some other uh tomorrow oh I see I see
take me you can kids if you consider the
blue part the green part the orange card
and the right part us all some about
some game and improve participe for that
game possibly you still be issued well
the issue is partly is it a small gamer
big game because like these red these
blue things and green and and so on they
all they're all just constant kita games
but but this red stuff at all links
together into into big sort of spaghetti
so you still have to mix that and
somehow whatever theorem you stated
would have to allow that that part a
mixed in so yeah I just want to clarify
that the comment yeah I didn't say it
right it's just that the way you can
express one of these measurement based
on the invitation in either one way or
the other like the more one way
completely computation like Aslam versus
the multiplication right style it's a
little reminiscent of how the duplicate
values prepare measure and the entangled
and Penguin purification for the boost
not like the way you did compose it
allows you to and the most offensive
public structure what you see I don't
think it makes it easier i mean i don't
know i mean it's a trivial
correspondence between this
teleportation and disease cluster state
stuff so it's not gonna give you any
technical tools agree with you on that
yeah lumpy sorry yeah
might be miss something I'm just
wondering like in your in this diagram
that you can't analyze except for the
part that's actually performing a
computation that's going to have to be
adaptive based on the outcomes of the
measurements right um everything
everything else at least conceptually
whether you have the CHS edge games
happening first or second I mean it's
all the same thing right or at least you
if you consider this just one big block
whether where the CH SH games are being
played because it doesn't matter like
there's no time ordering on this well
there has to be a time ordering if you
if you if you want to hide this part
you're going to have to have a time
ordering and you're going to have to
also like like this like when you do a
bell measurement like this it's in the
actual protocol here it's a bell
measurement to pain random pairs of
qubits so you need to be able to you
know keep it one and keep it a thousand
and be able to check that alice is doing
that ok so that they're labeled the
label of the interesting also this
protocol is adaptive to it's necessarily
adaptive because teleportation is
adaptive so there's also a time ordering
for that like I think maybe are you
asking about reducing around complexity
or about mixing up the different blocks
and improve yeah I mean this is a little
bit big but I was just sort of wondering
why you can't if you have something
ordered that looks like this you can't
just imagine that the CHS educated for
being played first for the purposes of
analyzing quite possible you could if
you if you had the kind of theorem that
was strong enough then you can you might
be able to do that I mean we can make
assumptions like that like for example
when when we analyze these tomography
protocols again these Bob's being asked
to prepare resource dates on random
pairs of qubits but in the analysis we
say by symmetry might as well just
assume things doing it in sequence 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 it might be the same serve
ideas what you're saying ok thanks